hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein kurzes video und zwar
wegen meiner fernsehsendung heute ist
auch übrigens heute also ich habe jetzt
gerade um 14 uhr 30 ungefähr das video
gefilmt und gleich hochgeladen und die
spülmaschine geht komischerweise immer
dann an wenn ich rede
naja egal ich wollte wegen eurem
feedback zur fernsehsendung business
sagen also mich hat es ein bisschen
näher eigentlich nicht erstaunt aber
andere vielleicht ein bisschen und zwar
habe ich ja meine bald meine eigene
fernsehsendungen haben den casting
aufruf gestartet und ihr dürft euch bei
mir bewerben also kinder zwischen acht
und 18 kinder und jugendliche dürfen
sich bei mir bewerben um gemeinsam mit
mir in meiner küche eine torte zu backen
für eine person die ihr gerne
überraschen möchte
und jetzt waren so viele kommentare da
und vor allem ganz viele kommentare von
menschen die über 18 sind und die sich
jetzt ein bisschen benachteiligt fühlen
weil sie leider nicht mit mir in der
küche kochen und backen können
ich habe hier übrigens gerade noch mein
rezept drin für das video warte ich muss
kurz nachgucken kaum gehen wir mit rein
vielleicht kann die aufnahme gleich
verwenden kontakt
das wird nämlich einen glauben kann es
gut den hohen ball gleich raus so kurz
mit trance verein spielen damit er schön
glänzt
wie wird der oettinger jetzt sagen live
stream der lämmer life in the kitchen an
die du kannst alles rausholen und ich
mache hier einfach weiter ich habe den
anfang nämlich versprochen wir schneiden
das video nicht damit da keine arbeit
damit hat ja jedenfalls haben ganz viele
geschrieben im säli ich bin schon über
wieso darf ich nicht mit dir kochen und
backen in deiner küche und es hat
einfach folgenden grund also das ist ja
sozusagen unsere erste fernsehsendung
und ja das ist ja für uns auch neuland
wir haben so etwas noch nie gemacht wir
haben zwar schon über 800 youtube videos
gedreht aber fernsehen ist doch nur mal
ein bisschen was anderes und wir mussten
natürlich das ganze so ein bisschen ja
so ein bisschen wenigstens komprimieren
und sagen okay zwischen 8 und 18
mit acht jahren ist man nämlich als kind
schon so weit dass noch sagen kann ok
ich kann auch ein bisschen alleine
packen und das helle auch helfen und ich
hab's dann beschränkt auf 18 weil ich
finde das einfach kinder also durch die
fantasie einfach noch da und kinder sind
so wir sind noch nicht so eingefahren
wie erwachsene und wenn man übrigens
auch ja und die haben halt noch ihre
volle fantasie haben keine vorurteile
und habe gedacht mensch mit kindern kann
man das echt ganz gut machen
vor allem habe ich mir gedacht weil ich
ja momentan gerade nicht als lehrerin
arbeitet und kinder auch schon sehr
vermisst habe und die arbeit mit kindern
auch schon total vermisst habe dachte
ich mit kindern ist es eben ganz schön
und da kann ich einfach meine arbeit als
lehrerin wie das ein bisschen nachgehen
und ja einfach kinder zu mir einladen
ich möchte damit natürlich keinen
diskriminieren oder ausschließen und
viele augen haben auch aus österreich
geschrieben wie so dürfen wir denn nicht
teilnehmen
es ist einfach so wir sind ja dass das
unser baby projekt und wir müssen das
jetzt erstmal begrenzen wir haben auch
nur muss ich dazu sagen ein monat zeit
für die produktion und es werden vier
folgen und das ist schon ziemlich knapp
also für ein youtube-video klar brauche
ich nicht so lange
aber da kommt ja auch noch das kind mit
ins spiel ich möchte jetzt nichts essen
und wir müssen dann ja auch ein bisserl
was vom kind filmen und von daher sind
wir auch ein bischen und tor
ja soll ich noch dazu sagen also seid
mir deswegen nicht böse wenn die
so gut ankommt was ich hoffe wo ihr
natürlich auch eine große rolle spielt
in dem ihr das ganze verbreitet und
teilt und fleißig anschaut dann können
wir vielleicht bei der zweiten staffel
auch gerne das ganze in wissel erweitern
und sagen auch über 18 jährige dürfen
mit neuen stoffen ganz anderes vor markt
genau vielleicht wird auch ein ganz
anderes format das weiß ich ja noch
nicht jedenfalls wollte ich sagen ich
habe schon ganz viele e mails bekommen
und viele videos schon angeschaut
manche müssen übrigens darauf achten
dass die eingereichten videos die müsst
ihr auf nicht gelistet machen also nicht
auf privat sonst kann ich sie nämlich
nicht anschauen einfach auch nicht
gelistet und dann den link eben in dem
formular eingeben
woran hast du irgendwie adhs kinder
getauft
ich mache die denken ich mag die machen
mich ganz acacia jedenfalls denke ich
das war's jetzt soweit wir mischen und
setzen unsere suppe kümmern wir uns
nämlich gerade mittagspause mit dem team
apropos team kommen mal kurz kommen kann
ich jetzt gar nicht zeigen oder eine
lederhose an uns ja mal kommt ich zeigen
war das war so nicht abgesprochen geld
das sie am markt gesorgt hat gleich für
die richtige stimmung samira macht watch
mit bbb schmackes wachsen ist darf nicht
in museen achtet lippen geformt ihr
klippen geformt auf jeden fall mehr über
18 seid und euch trotzdem wir wollen
nicht dazu sagen warum eine lederhose
trios und weil wir gerade oktoberfest
thema haben hier bei uns in der kirche
und noch fleißig filmen und die jungs
inhalt perfekt genau ein gewisses berg
über 18 ist eine ganz kurz mit werden
die gehen dann mit mir zusammen ins
drachenland alles so ist das also schon
da war es schon gern ebenfalls werden
wir uns jetzt hinsetzen unser
mittagessen genießen selbst gemachte
gemüsebrühe mit moritz fürste und nudeln
haben wir jetzt gemacht so morgen wieder
neues video machen kommt neues und
samstag kommt ein video über unser neues
buchprojekt über sally and friends da
werde ich euch über das buch berichten
ein bisschen auch was zeigen ja und ich
wünsche uns im guten appetit
und ja bis zur nächsten wahl
servus